[Music]
so i want to share with you a quick five
minutes workout in the morning to give
you the energy you need to gently wake
your body up and for you to have a
productive day ahead it is going to
combine strength and also lots of gentle
stretches to really wake all the muscles
up so do this first thing in the morning
it is only five minutes but it is going
to make a huge difference to your day so
it's time to wake up
so we want to do each workout for one
minute each okay so in the morning i
want you to start by standing tall okay
always remember to maintain an upright
position and we want to really stretch
your entire body up so the first workout
is going to be inch worm to upwards dog
okay so start by standing tall shoulder
width apart toes pointed forward and
just lift your arms up okay hands
together stretch up and slowly bring
your body down inchworm
okay and really slowly get into a plank
and look up
and
slowly get back
okay so for each workout it is going to
be for one minute stretch it is all
about lengthening the spine
and slowly gently use your strength and
really wake your muscles up look up
feel the stretch on your lower back
and slowly inch back good
again up be aware of your breathing
stretch again
dive down
inch worm
into a nice solid plank
upwards dog look up
it's so good to do this workout first
thing in the morning to just you know
get your blood flowing in the body and
really feel
energized
good the second workout will be done
with stock to plank so we want to go the
reverse way so get into a plank and go
to downwards dog press your heels down
look between your legs push your butt up
get into a nice plank and solid plank
back to downwards dog okay so keep the
movement flowing
strong arms
do not hunch your shoulders press your
shoulders down
and back into downward stalk look
between your legs breathe feel your back
stretched out feel your core working
your shoulders your arms
nice keep going
so breathe in and breathe out into a
plank good breathe in
and out
again in
press down and out
in
heels on the floor but up stretch your
back and out
few more guys you're doing really well
one more
and out
and now maintain a plank position what
we want to do is to get into groiners
okay so left feet to your left
palm
and then back into a plank right to your
right palm okay
and remember again
in the morning it's all about looking up
it's all about giving thanks it's all
about giving gratitude
and pace your breathing up to the sky
breathe
up nice
so you should feel
your legs your hips flexors stretched
out and also your inner thighs being
stretched out if you want to increase
your heart rate you can hop into the
workout so from light right hop to left
look up and hop to right
nice
again hold the stretch for few seconds
nice
one last one on each side
stretch look up
and
nice back into a plank and just get up
into standing okay the next workout will
be squat with side stretches i'm already
sweating so again we want to stand tall
tall squat stretch to your side
tall squat stretch to your side
tall
and stretch nice
look up again or if you want to
look forward
remember when you bring your arms up
what you're doing is also opening your
chest up
and keeping your entire spine in a long
straight line so no forward bend
always remember
tall
squats okay
tall
and really squeeze your obliques and
stretch it out nice squeeze
few more
squeeze
keep going
this short workout will really wick your
muscles up at the same time
you will be sweating
good
so final workout will be lunge
and we want to open up good so back
lunge forward and open up so in the
morning it is all about bringing in all
the good energy
to your body and also mind open up look
up
stretch and up open your chest really
feel the stretch on your chest and back
so i want you to keep the back leg
strong
and lunge back okay so remember back leg
strong do not wobble and bring it back
be conscious of your butt muscles
working your thigh muscles working and
you will feel them even more good back
stretch
through your hip flexors at the same
time
open up look up
you shoot for your chest and your upper
back
keep going guys
few more seconds open
positive thoughts first thing in the
morning will make a huge difference to
your day and also perspective
and back
and that was your five minutes morning
workout for you to have a productive day
ahead hop into the shower and get ready
if you are someone that constantly feel
tired lack of energy or if you can't
sleep at night then add this quick five
minutes into your morning routine if you
stay consistent i can assure you that
you will feel so much better have more
energy be more productive and you will
feel amazing and do also watch the
recommended videos right at the end if
you find that you love this workout you
are sweaty and you feel energetic then
do like this video share it and
subscribe to my youtube channel for new
weekly videos and guys i want you to
have an amazing day ahead all the best
[Music]
you